米ちゃ俺ポケモンを待った波戸氏ポケモン
マスターで名乗ってるけど最近のポケット
もさん想像しているどのランクマッチの
戦績は13勝17敗ゴミや y です
モンバサじゃないですこのままだとヤバい
ですそうハード次第にポケモンにハマっ
てるんですけど[ __ ]悩んでおりましてし
しか浅いんですよカトショーも大司教
バトルで書けない人もそうだと思うんだ
けども知識を買ったりたんですよポケモン
のあの知識へですからね果たしそこで思っ
たらまず何をすればいいとかと言いますと
ポケモンのタイプしっかりと覚えることが
大事だと思ったんだでボリュームのタイプ
たくさんあるんですけどもノーマルほのお
みずでんきくさこおり書くとどっち面
ひこうエスパーむしいわゴスとドラゴン
あくはがねせあり
ポケモンのタイプ18種類あるんですよね
その台風によってですね効果抜群のタイプ
が合ったリアルタイプにあの抗議をすると
放火がいまひとつだったり効果がないとか
もあるんでタイプを覚えるのを疑問バトル
で一番大事だと思うんだかとしていたけど
覚えれないあまりに多すぎてなく基本的な
奴は分かるでしょもちろんや0最近の
アヌシータイプやら墓ねおーすと悪
フェアリー格闘思考とかのそこらへんの
アン形成がいまいちわからないし皆さんも
わからない方多いと思うんですよ話バカだ
からくせにって多いんだな部分なんで本体
釜座9点とか効果抜群とかコーナー今一つ
を分かりやすくそのタイプがなぜその
タイプに効果抜群なのかそのタイプには
効果がいまひとつなのか紐解いて教えてし
たいと思いますつまりこの動画を見るわ
君もポケモンマスターで愛甲
様子というわけでちょっと本当に分かり
やすく説明していきましょうまずはこちら
ですこれも結構わかりやすい気がしますね
格闘タイプのマザーはノーマルタイプ2校
が抜群なんですこれなぜかと言いますと
もう皆さんもメニューて分かります通り
一般人のなぜかは点心が戦ったとし
ましょう夏川停車のパンチ絶対公が抜群な
んですよ一般人からすると強いすもこれを
と特防がで水と思いますねノーマルタイプ
に格闘 the 効果抜群です次ゴースト
タイプの技はどうあるタイプに効果がない
んですよなぜかと言いますと普通の人間
ってデーかないんです一般人はだからそう
いう霊感がない人に幽霊が
で打っても意味がないこれすなわち
ゴーストタイプの技はノーマルタイプには
こう書かないをバイロイトけど設立は
ちょっと炎タイプが喰らう端について話し
ていきましょうタイプにこのタイプが公開
今一つこれもなんとなく分かると思います
同族同じ微難で効果があまりないという
ことですこのタイプに水タイムの攻撃は
効果抜群これは分かりますあの炎に水だけ
で消えますこのタイプに草タイプの攻撃は
子が今一つこれわかります燃えている炎に
臭いでて百恵ちゃんでこれも公開今一つ
ですこの台風に氷タイプの攻撃が公開今一
つこれももう全然に俺がとっちゃうんで
効果があまりないです炎タイプに地面と
海馬タイプの攻撃が効果パッすぐこれを水
と同じ件です覚えてるほどにツナと
ガチャリとか石ころ投げると聞いうんで炎
が消えるイメージを膨らませておけば
クラス落としやすいかと思いますその
タイプにムースタイプの技が公開が一つ
これをはかですよと思います虫歯います次
に炎タイプにはがねタイプの攻撃が効果は
いまひとつこれなぜかと言いますと羽って
も簡単には鉄なんですよねメタル熱すぎる
炎だと溶けちゃうんで効果はいまひとつに
なってしまいますこれがちょっとわから
ですねこのタイプにフェアリータイプの
講義が効果はいまひとつフェアリーが
ちょっと良くイメージつかないんですけど
も僕からやらせてみると中森の精霊王って
いうイメージを考えてみてくださいで
フェアリータイプとも思う皆様森の精霊王
たと思ってください森の精霊なんで森に
住んでるんですよ石津草タイプっぽい空気
があるんですよねちょっとなので炎タイプ
に攻撃をしてもフェアで羽根とかって燃え
ちゃうんでこの台場行きませんということ
でこのタイプに攻撃してもここは今一つと
いうことになります続いて水大会が攻撃を
受ける時水タイプにはがねタイプの砲撃が
効果今一つらこれはでもわかりやすいです
ね金属のもの海とかに持っていくと錆びる
とユーザーですからの白蜜とかねぇ
そういうイメージとこれ全部たら終わらん
だともうちょっと明らかにこれはおかしい
でしょみたいなタイプ相性を見ていき
ましょう飛行タイプにこおりタイプの技が
効果発これもちょっと何か想像しづらいと
思うんですけどもあのこれ簡単な話で
ちょっと見る鳥がいるじゃないですか
フリーの羽を両方凍らせたら墜落します
以上効果抜群です line でみんなに
母数使用タイプ相性後お願い疑問に思っ
てるんだろうなぁドラゴンタイプにほのお
みずでんきくさ全部聞かないんですよこれ
なぜかでいいましたもういろんなからも
いるわけですよもう炎円する泥水を愛する
ドラゴン勉強操る打刻さを操るドラム
いろんな苦労んはいるんでこういうなんか
あの何 rpg っていうメインの属性と
なるあのほのおみずでんき属性みたいな
こういう4つの属性はドラゴンに聞かん
ですよって効果今一つ覚えておきましょう
なんですけどもなぜかドラゴンというか
コーリータイプのはから効果抜群なんです
よこれなぜかと言いますとドラゴンを創造
するというより恐竜を想像した方がいいか
もですね恐竜なんで絶滅したと思います
今日楽器なんですそうで鮫さんにはいいん
ですよ彼らよってこおりタイプの技は効果
抜群ですこれ教上の表 gackt
掛け合わさってるんですかねえとドラゴン
の弱点と2つあるんですよねドラゴン
タイプにドラゴンタイプの攻撃が効果抜群
なんですドラマってこう孤独に逝ける
生き物なのであの友達があまりいないん
ですよねでその3つとの遭遇の塔ドラゴン
送ることによって前こと戦いなで会津の
ポーチがめちゃくちゃ聞いたりする猫が
抜群です
こじつけ阿蘇はフェアリータイプのどの
方向か抜群なんですよねこれなぜかと言い
ますと先ほど話したよう性をの話ですねん
から
ドラゴンに襲われている村を救う取って
精霊を気がしません
だからです
悪タイプのポケモンにミスタイプの砲撃が
効果抜群なのが謎だとなので雑誌日に開く
って基本的に人間的なものにはとっても
強く出るんですね例えば例を挙げると
エスパータイプの攻撃悪タイプ効果がない
んですけど悪しき心が強すぎてそういう
最高的な聴力減少と効かないんですよ心が
もささみすぎてそれが開くタイプですなの
でゴーストタイプの講義も公害も一つなん
ですよねなぜかと言いますと声を乗せだっ
たんですよ山本例えば人間なんでその人間
の像とかそういうのもここから
押さえつける声がこれが開くタイプ基本的
に人間関係には2と思ってくださいただ
弱点が2つだけありましてそのうちの1つ
が格闘タイプはもう想像しやすいと思うん
ですけども正義と悪戦ったらそれじゃあ
正義が勝つという感じでもうずに強さを
埋める格闘家正義ですね書くとタイプが
開くに勝つというイメージですボッコボコ
にされておりませんで貼る人ってかわいい
地面があるんですよね例えばめちゃくちゃ
虫が嫌いだとかなんか悪い人ってそういう
可愛い一面があるんですよねめちゃくちゃ
いかついおじさんがある俺ん星無理なん
だあああみたいなこのイメージを使い
ましょう皆さん効果抜群です後は格闘
タイプ飛行タイプの関係もちょっと難しい
ですね格闘タイプに飛行タイプが桜が抜群
これなぜかと言いますと地に足つけて戦う
んですよね各党が入ってください取れず
あの空飛んでる人にはローピックが効か
ないんですよねペリッとかがまず入れない
でつつ闊達からの半分も出せないような気
がします光タイプの先頭には誰でも拮抗的
に上からこう書くとがつかれており水を
想像してみてくださいなぜか飛行艇ば速い
んでめちゃくちゃスピードでも放浪され
てる目で掴んでいきましょう格闘だいたい
モコは世論など全部買わせるんで氷とか
言わんとった墓にとも金属も武力で全部
切っ地区はそういう固形物相手には全部
効果が強い中を覚えておいてくださいあと
格闘のザク店といえばエスパーもザクて
ですねフェアリータイプの技も効果抜群な
んですよねフェアリーもなんか魔法使いっ
ぽい空気があるんでちょっとエスパーとか
線ざっ提供しますホンダが超能力とこの
マジカル
シャイニーな羽で肩が動き止められて魔法
でボコボコにされてる目で掴んでおき
ましょうまたフェアリータイプに毒タイプ
が効果抜群もうこれは重水にこうめっちゃ
純粋潔白な綺麗な人が毒に侵されている
イメージを想像してください美しいものの
弱点であった汚いものなんですよつまり
ドッグでこう綺麗な学者苦心されてる
イメージがすごい想像つくと思います覚え
ておきましょうあとフェアリーの着てもう
一つあるんですけどはがねタイプの技も
ポート抜群なんですよなぜかと言いますと
めっちゃくっちゃ簡単にまとめると鋼って
も位はメタル機会なんですよ機械現代科学
ですここのフェアリーと鋼を退治された時
に想像してほしいのがもうフェアリーが
妄想自然界最強最近だと現代家具の強いん
ですよ魔法とかを凌駕するその機械の力で
エアリーを破壊するこのイメージをつかん
でおきましょう
はっはっってどれ
こうするしかないんだよ毒タイプですね毒
たいもうちょっと難しいですねよくわかり
づらいと思います毒タイプの攻撃が公開今
一つのタイプは同じどくじめんいわ
ゴーストがありますこの4つに関連するの
は4つとも生き物じゃないんですよどこか
だか本当に得対独でちょっと今一つって
いう意味さつくんですけども地面と言われ
とかゴーストてもいい今日じゃないんで
そう損得状態にならないというイメージを
掴んでおいてくださいねゴースタイプに
凍っタイプの技公が抜群なのはちょっと
意味がわからないという意見頂きました
あの
なんででしょ go スタートボスと簡単
に言いますと幽霊て人間にしか強いことし
ないじゃないですかなので逆にと人間以外
のものが怖いんですよだからもうゴースト
とゴースト同じゴースト同士が来戦うと
思うお互い強いからすげーダメージが強い
んですよ効果抜群後開くタイプの攻撃が
ゴーストタイプに効果抜群これなぜかと
言いますと悪やっぱ結局強い邪悪ってと
いうのが幽霊の精神攻撃とかも全く効き
ませんばるすべてお化けいたら普通にブン
投げます悪い人は約タイプのはたら
エスパータイプに効果抜群もこれは簡単
ですねこれも同じく精神攻撃して今では
ため超能力者をこの悪人がぶん殴ったり
練習つかんでおきましょう後は基本的に何
かそういう腸炎力とが使うてね効かないと
いうイメージですパウダーやっぱりすべて
の頂点に立つ情勢フェアリーには効果抜群
ねそこだけ
運び変わる
tre
悪タイプなど分かりやすい前ザック体が
本当正義の格闘タイプ意外と虫が嫌いと
いう虫タイプステイすべての位置ものそう
伝達であり以上ですこれが3つの鮭結構謎
っぽいところは言った気がしますけどね
あとははがねタイプの攻撃ができたように
効果はいまひとつだが電気で実体がない
じゃないですか火病って書かれ何も曲早
すぎてキングの剣とかピョンちゃっても
なかっおっ症って交わされるみたいな
イメージするので効果はいまひとつです
実体がないものと彼にはちょっと弱いかも
ですねならねあのはがねタイプの攻撃は炎
とか水とかにも弱い相手はちょっと実態が
なさげなんでその代わり氷には効果抜群
ですね鋼行為と金属ぶつけたかわかる
でしょう
バッハ
氷がこの場です効果抜群です茨大部に跳ね
タイプの砲撃が効果抜群も同じ感じです
銀座口と言わをぶつけてみてください
ぷっ
[音楽]
金属が勝ちますまあこんなところじゃない
ですかねちょっとややこしいのは一つ僕今
めちゃくちゃこじつけていろいろしゃべっ
たんですけども結局は脳内でアイプがあっ
たときにどれが効くかどうかを過ぎ生
できれば絶対尾木ママ春厨も問題なく
いけると思うんでランドが皆さん自分の脳
みそでタイプアイスをしっかり覚えて雪の
ポジョン大町た目指して頑張ろうぜっ
pou
dou
[音楽]
th